the world of breath of the wild is huge
and the developers have offered many
ways for you to travel across the
massive landscapes but over the years
players have preferred some less
conventional methods by air
so today i'll be covering 33 techniques
and some variations of them small and
large to launch and fly across the land
of hyrule and do a very light
explanations for each nothing too in
depth if you enjoy a breath of the wild
videos from us let us know with a like
it helps us to make more videos for you
stasis launch
one of the most iconic ways to travel in
breath of the wild stasis launch
consists of hitting yourself with a
heavy object with maximum momentum while
jumping in the air
this will send link careening in that
direction and give him a good boost of
speed when he opens his paraglider
rocket launch a slightly different
variation with a different outcome this
version starts out the same but instead
of hitting yourself you climb on the
object and go along for the ride doesn't
go quite as far but if you don't have
the paraglider yet it can give you a
safe landing option
[Music]
box walk another classic but this allows
link to walk on the box as the object is
launched objects often turn slowly while
getting launched so in order for link
not to fall off in this manner the cool
walk forward is needed to fly with the
box
guardian airship definitely one of the
stranger methods of flying this takes
advantage of a certain bug that allows
guardian stalkers to take to the skies
by cutting off the guardian's legs then
placing it on top of a boat the guardian
starts to mysteriously float skyward
magnesius chest launch one of the
easiest ways to fly upwards in the game
by simply standing on the very chest
magnesius in the chest will knock it out
of the ground and launch link upwards to
get some nice airtime
daruk's perfect launch one of the more
difficult and inconsistent methods of
launching this requires several things
you must perform a perfect parry with
deruk's protection by releasing zl right
as a bomb detonates and at the exact
time step up onto a small ledge if done
correctly link will take to the skies
with style
kibako launch by placing a bomb and link
on opposite ends of the box detonating
it will send link flying through the air
instead of just falling to the ground
this can be only performed with wooden
boxes though metal ones won't work in
this case
ladder launch
these ladder towers can be destroyed
with a bomb so by jumping onto them as
they are destroyed climbing it will
immediately shoot you to the top doing a
hold smuggle which is another glitch
forcing you to hold an item while this
is happening will shoot you skyward
instead
by placing a horse downhill with his
rear legs up then shield jumping in
place as you mount the horse on the
backside will set up for the beginning
of the glitch then go for a small ride
in the forward direction dismounting
will then cause link to fly backwards at
high speeds and go for a nice flight
sliding same concept as horse sliding
but using a tree instead between the
master cycles tires will also set up the
same trick again go for a quick ride
forward then dismount for a quick zip
backwards
octo balloon snap launch using a glitch
to attach a octo balloon to an object to
yourself stasising the balloon then
putting yourself between a heavy object
it will aggressively snap back to you
after stasis and launch the item you're
on and you along with it
[Music]
moon jumping while not the fastest
method of travel it is one of the most
versatile allowing link to jump to any
height at any time with no stamina or
health needed mounting a wild horse but
not taming it during the mounted archery
mini game then warping away allows you
to jump to the heavens
super soul launch
moon jump also sets up for some other
lesser-known ways to travel by mounting
the lynel and osira planes instead of a
horse then separating your camera from
link then ancient arrowing the lynel
pulling out your paraglider will cause
link's soul to snap back into his body
and send him greening into the distance
slipping over almost every obstacle in
the way definitely one of the tougher
ones to perform
another trick only available while in
the moon jump state flying chest
requires some very specific footwork by
having one foot slightly over the edge
of the chest magnesius in the chest will
lift link upwards and ascend him to the
skies
this reminds me of another similar trick
flying machine cart version flying
machine is one of the oldest ways to
travel across hyrule magnesius seeing
the lower mine cart sandwiches the upper
mine cart between you and link taking
you skyward
flying machine box version this can also
be performed with a metal box but
unfortunately this version can be a
little more
wobbly
death mountain shield block reset
possibly the most inefficient way to get
height this combines shrine apparatus
storage 2.0 and drowning lava bow
smuggling then shield block resetting
with a strong shield over and over to
climb the stairway to heaven with flashy
style just don't expect to last too
long momentum transfer there are several
variations of this technique but the
most standard case is to use it after
any ragdolling launch which you then
watch a memory then load a file you'll
load back in but already flying skyward
horse momentum transfer this is the same
process but without needing to watch a
memory instead loading immediately after
being hit by a stasis object loading
back in on a saved horse will allow you
to dismount wherever you'd like and
rocket skywars
bullet time bounce
one of the most famous ways to navigate
the world bullet time bounces allow link
to gain massive speed and air time by
shield surfing onto a low level headshot
or frozen enemy in bullet time hitting
them will cause lane to fly off into the
sunset this can include bigger enemies
such as the henox and its eye
mulduga or talus bounce many attacks
including the mulduga's tail whips and
the talus punches can be a nice
launching platform for a quick
commercial flight across the land by
shield jumping just as the attack
strikes you link will bounce off and go
flying across hyrule
henoc's arm launch taking to the skies
for the master cycle is pretty easy with
the helping hand of a henox literally
jumping onto its hand spooks it to get
up quickly knocking you and the bike
upward for some decent air time
master cycle cryonis launch entering
bullet time then mounting the bike
quickly just as the cryoness block lifts
it sends link skyward for a massive
skyward boost
stasis bounce while it looks similar to
stasis launching it's much different
since you're in the shield surf
animation instead lining yourself up to
a metal box then shield surf jumping
just as the box strikes you causes you
to get a massive launch similar to
bullet time bounces
[Music]
cryonus bounce by using a waterfall's
vertical angle and spawning a crown is
blocked sideways it can be used as a
horizontal launch pad to jet across the
world quickly sometimes you can even go
so fast to skim across a surface of
ground or water just like skipping a
rock on a pond
bomb launch a technique that most casual
players get confused with wind bombs
bomb launching uses both remote bombs
placed on the ground in a specific order
with bullet time landing between the
bombs sideways and bullet time pushes
link out aggressively and sends him
flying off into the distance this is
much more difficult than it looks
wind bomb you've probably been waiting
for this one
the basic front hop or backflip wind
bomb is the most standard way that
everybody knows by detonating the
farthest bomb and pushing the closer
bomb into link the impact rockets link
up up and away
bullet time wind bombs this combines any
glitch or technique that forces bullet
time on open ground such as shield lock
presets jelly bouncing and shield jump
cancels to get wind bombs off of
completely flat ground certainly is more
for the style points and can be tricky
to pull off
midair or linear wind bombs
neutral gliding in place then dropping
the bombs or lining them up both at
bullet time and full speeds allows you
to get a wind bomb mid-air these of
course can be chained together to get
tons of height and distance over time
vertical wind bombs these wind bombs go
almost straight up sacrificing distance
for verticality placing the bomb in
front of a curb then back flipping
quickly over it you can sandwich the
bombs between each other like a pillar
allowing for a launch straight up
spider-wind bombs pretty standard wind
bombs but maybe a little peter parker
energy thrown in the mix by jumping off
a climbable wall first gotta say it's
pretty stylish
bomb arrow wind bumps while it's not
particularly efficient bomb arrows can
substitute as a remote bomb as well
launching link just like any normal wind
bomb would
blss the newest addition to the bunch
blss uses several glitches together to
hover and fly across hyrule with ease
using no stamina or health there are
multiple variations and movement types
blss offers by holding different items
or even different stances such as when
link has zero arrows we got a video all
about this on our channel
and that's it there are many other small
variations of launch techniques here and
there but these are the most unique and
well-known ones if you like this video
or want us to explain some of these more
in depth let us know in the comments
below and of course for everything else
gaming stay tuned right here on gamespot
[Music]
you